[Música]
alemania eslovaquia y hungría se
saltaron el disparo inicial en la
carrera de la vacunación masiva de la
unión europea y comenzaron a aplicar la
fórmula de facer y variante que un día
antes de la fecha prevista
los beneficios de desempleo para
millones de estadounidenses afectados
por la pandemia expiran hoy mientras que
el paquete de ayudas económicas
permanece bloqueado por el presidente
saliente de donald trump
pero no todos perdieron en 2020 empresas
tecnológicas se valorizaron algunos
emprendedores lograron adaptarse y
aprovechar estas tecnologías para
mejorar su vida hablamos con una familia
campesina colombiana que triunfó en
youtube
hola cómo están qué gusto saludarlos y
bienvenidos a las noticias aquí en
france 24 la unión europea esperaba
lanzar su campaña de vacunación contra
el cob y 19 en bloque este domingo 27 de
diciembre con la fórmula de facer y
bayonne tec pero alemania hungría y
eslovaquia se han adelantado y
comenzaron sus inmunizaciones desde hoy
la campaña de vacunación trae esperanza
a un continente que supera ya los 25
millones de casos y también batalla para
superar una segunda ola de la pandemia
después de haber sido duramente golpeada
por la primera y que ahora además
enfrenta el temor de la nueva cepa del
virus allá del reino unido- y que ya
llegó a francia y españa donde fueron
detectados casos de esta mutación que se
cree es más contagiosa
la unión europea anunció que de manera
coordinada este domingo se aplicarían en
todo el bloque las primeras dosis de la
vacuna de las farmacéuticas fisher y
bryant pero varios países se adelantaron
hungría empezó la inoculación del
personal de la salud tan sólo horas
después de haber recibido su primer
cargamento de las dosis a éste se unió a
alemania donde el programa de vacunación
empezó en el estado de sajonia-anhalt en
un hogar de adultos mayores la jornada
se anticipó porque dijeron tener la
infraestructura lista allí la primera en
vacunarse fue una mujer de 101 años
eslovaquia tampoco quiso quedarse atrás
un integrante de la comisión de
pandemias del gobierno fue el primero en
recibir la dosis sin ningún problema ni
siquiera me di cuenta que me estaban
vacunando se siente menos que la
picadura de un mosquito que va a tomar o
sí pero los cargamentos de facer y
beyoncé llegaron este sábado a varios
países de la unión europea
la vacuna da esperanza a países como
francia italia y españa los más
golpeados tanto por la primera como por
la nueva ola de contagios estamos
empezando a pasar la página a un año
difícil la vacunación nos ayudará a
recuperar
la vida normal gradualmente la
presidenta de la comisión europea-
ursula von der leyen dijo que pronto
habrá más vacunas cuando se compruebe su
efectividad y agregó que el bloque ya ha
asegurado las suficientes dosis para
vacunar a sus 450 millones de habitantes
en américa latina sólo tres países han
comenzado sus campañas de vacunación
méxico chile y costa rica revisemos
noticias destacadas que deja la pandemia
en la región
en méxico que fue el primer país de la
región en vacunar a sus ciudadanos ya
llegó un segundo lote con 42 mil 900
dosis de la vacuna de facer bayón tec al
aeropuerto internacional de la capital
asimismo aterrizaron en la norteña
ciudad de monterrey otras 8 mil 775
dosis todas eran para vacunar al
personal médico méxico registra más de
un millón 372 mil casos de kobe 19 y 121
mil fallecidos
en chile es el segundo país de américa
latina en vacunar y el primero de
sudamérica más de 5000 médicos y
enfermeras ya han recibido la vacuna en
las últimas 24 horas chile registró 2
mil 564 nuevos contagios la cifra más
alta desde julio cuando estuvo al borde
del colapso de los hospitales alcanzando
un total de 598 mil 394 desde marzo
se cumplen 10 meses desde la llegada del
virus a américa latina' el 26 de febrero
en brasil cuando se registró el primer
positivo de kobe 19 hoy el gigante
sudamericano registra casi 7 millones y
medio de contagios y 190.000 muertes y
celebrará el fin de año bajo una
estricta cuarentena en la mayor parte de
su territorio ante el avance del virus
de sudamérica nos vamos al norte del
continente porque millones de
estadounidenses pierden hoy la ayuda por
desempleo debido a la decisión del
presidente de donald trump de no firmar
el proyecto de ley de ayudas que había
sido consensuado por demócratas y
republicanos en el congreso citrón no lo
firma antes de la medianoche los
desempleados dejarán de recibir
prestaciones al menos una semana o
durante el tiempo que tarde alcanzaron
un acuerdo al respecto el presidente
electo joe biden advirtió que la
decisión de trump traerá consecuencias
devastadoras
todo está en manos del presidente
y donaldson no pone su nombre en el
proyecto de ley de estímulo cerca de 14
millones de estadounidenses pierden los
beneficios por desempleo
un acuerdo había sido logrado luego de
meses de negociaciones tortuosa entre
los demócratas y republicanos en el
congreso
pero a inicios de esta semana el
presidente de trump se rehusó a firmar
el proyecto de ley diciendo que los 600
dólares de ayuda estipulados para los
individuos no eran suficientes
es le pido al congreso que enmiende este
proyecto de ley y aumente los
ridículamente bajos 600 dólares a 2000
el proyecto de ley que ahora planean
enviar a mi escritorio es muy diferente
de lo previsto es realmente una
desgracias es grace palabras que tomaron
al congreso por sorpresa swap no se
opuso al acuerdo el pasado lunes cuando
fue sometido a votación y de hecho eran
los demócratas los que habían insistido
en que los estadounidenses deberían
recibir un monto más alto de berna
créanlo o no los demócratas están de
acuerdo con el presidente 600 dólares no
son suficientes para los individuos que
la han pasado mal durante los últimos
siete meses y no son suficientes para
darle un impulso a las necesidades de
nuestra economía con el veto trompón e
millones de dólares de ayuda económica
en el limbo incluyendo 286 mil millones
para las familias y los desempleados 284
mil millones para los pequeños negocios
y 70 mil millones para las vacunas y
pruebas de kobe 19 también dentro del
acuerdo está la pausa en las órdenes de
desalojos sin ella millones de personas
perderán sus casas
el proyecto de ley fue acordado por 1.4
billones de dólares lo que significa que
el gobierno estaría forzado a cerrar el
lunes si trump
decide no firmar
los confinamientos por la pandemia han
aumentado el uso de las nuevas
tecnologías y del mundo digital sitios
como google microsoft skype zone
facebook netflix y youtube han resultado
enormemente beneficiosa este año
precisamente una familia colombiana que
vive en una zona rural de cundinamarca
ahora es reconocida por figurar en la
lista de los youtubers más destacados de
latinoamérica en 2020 agradecemos esta
la comunicación con nubia gaona cabeza
de hogar tras la muerte de su esposo
hace dos años y que con sus hijos
comenzó con su primer vídeo en youtube
hace 7 meses para contar cómo viven las
familias campesinas en su región no voy
a ganar nuevamente gracias por esta
comunicación cuál era su situación
financiera antes de la pandemia y cómo
decidieron incursionar en youtube
buenas noches
y el canal se basó pues
la verdad que mi hijo ya visitó el
miraba los canales de youtube que
ninguno miraba educativo que algo fuera
desconocido para las personas
y nos decidimos enlazar e instalar
podemos sembrar en apartamentos y
empresas para que ninguno nos tengamos
te acostás nada de comer
qué harán con estos recursos obtenidos
de youtube cuáles son sus planes a
futuro
bueno pues con lo del canal de youtube
ya tenemos para la parte de nuestro
nuestro look
por la recta de crisis nosotros todos
he podido tenerle habitaciones adecuadas
a mis hijos para que tengan ellos para
poder dormir
como la situación de colombia de la vida
de campo
cómo está la situación en colombia de la
vida de campo
bueno pues el área del campo es muy
difícil en los próximos
cultivan sus productos pero como cultiva
y la vende y tos enfermedades y pues de
intermediarios pues el producto del
campesinado no lo pagarán precios
a meta de 3 entonces es prácticamente
está ofreciendo estas 300 el asunto es
tan mentados una página en las tiendas
estado y de los amigos partes en las que
les estamos ayudando a vender con
ustedes estables y sin intermediarios
señora gaona pues enhorabuena que sigan
los éxitos y los mejores deseos para su
familia en estas fechas
nubia gaona muchas gracias nuevamente
por esta comunicación que ustedes muchas
gracias por su compañía lo invitamos a
que siga con más noticias y al momento
aquí en france 24 y en france 24 punto
com
[Música]